Nos dicen que la fórmula...
la fórmula para encontrar el perímetro de un rectángulo
es "P" igual a "2l" más "2w",
donde "P" es el perímetro,
"l" es el largo y "w" es el ancho
y para visualizar lo que nos están pidiendo,
aunque quizás tú ya estás familiarizado con esto hagamos aquí un rectángulo.
Esto parece un rectángulo,
si este lado mide "l",
el lado opuesto también mediría "l"
entonces si este lado de aquí es el ancho que mide "w",
el opuesto también mide "w",
el perímetro es la distancia que hay
que recorrer para darle una vuelta al rectángulo,
entonces ese perímetro lo podemos calcular
como "w" más "l" más "w" más "l"
y aquí si agrupamos los términos semejantes
tenemos "w" aquí y "w" aquí esto es "2w"
más tenemos "l" aquí y "l" acá más "2l"
y ya tenemos que el perímetro es "2l" más "2w",
acá arriba lo pusieron de manera distinta
como lo escribimos nosotros,
pero al final de cuentas es la misma fórmula
para el perímetro "P" y la pregunta es,
reescribe la fórmula para encontrar el ancho...
para encontrar el ancho.
La fórmula como la tenemos ahorita
dice "p" es igual a algo,
lo que ellos nos piden una fórmula para "w"
una fórmula que nos diga que "w" es igual a algo,
donde van a aparecer "P",
"w" y un montón de número ahí mezclados.
Veamos cómo podemos hacer esto.
Nos dicen, nos están dando que
"P" es igual a "2l" más "2w"
si queremos una fórmula para calcular el ancho, "w", necesitamos despejar a "w",
para eso podemos empezar eliminando
la "l" de este lado de la ecuación
para lograr esto sin que se altere nuestra ecuación, restamos "2l" de ambos lados de la ecuación.
Hagámoslo así, entonces restamos "2l"
del lado derecho y también lo restamos...
"2l" también restamos "2l" del lado izquierdo,
acuérdate, aquí arriba teníamos la ecuación
"P" es igual a "2l" más "2w",
si estás restando "2l" del lado derecho,
también hay que restarle "2l" a "P",
lo que hagas de un lado de una ecuación
hay que hacerlo del otro lado de la ecuación
para que no se altere la igualdad.
¿Qué tenemos entonces?
Del lado izquierdo nos queda,
"P" menos "2l" es igual a...
es igual a "2l" menos "2l", se cancelan,
para eso hicimos todo esto, estos dos términos
se cancelan y nos queda tan solo "2w"
y ya casi llegamos, ya casi despejamos "w",
para esto necesitamos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre 2
y la razón de esto, de dividir ambos lados entre 2
es deshacernos de este coeficiente 2,
de este 2 que está multiplicando a "w".
Entonces dividiendo
ambos lados de la ecuación entre 2,
de nueva cuenta si haces algo de un lado
lo tienes que hacer del otro lado,
la razón por la que dividí entre 2 es que 2
multiplicado por algo dividido entre 2 nos da ese algo,
así es que del lado derecho tenemos tan solo "w"
y el lado izquierdo así se queda y ya hemos acabado,
si giramos, si invertimos esta ecuación,
tenemos entonces que "w",
"w" es igual a todo esto que tenemos acá,
es "P" menos "2l"
y todo eso "P" menos "2l" dividido entre 2.
Ahora, esta es la respuesta correcta,
la fórmula que nos piden,
sin embargo hay otra manera de escribirla,
esto lo voy a reescribir como,
déjame primero marcar esto porque definitivamente esto es una respuesta válida
a lo que nos están pidiendo,
esta es la respuesta correcta,
pero hay otras maneras de escribir esta fórmula,
tú también podrías haber hecho lo siguiente
que es un camino también válido para llegar
a la solución, déjame hacerlo por acá,
nuestra fórmula original es
"P" es igual a "2l" más "2w",
¿qué tal si factorizamos ahora
el 2 de esta expresión?
A ver, hagámoslo claro por qué,
aquí tenemos un 2 y aquí tenemos otro 2,
podemos factorizar 2 del lado derecho,
así es que nos queda "P" es igual a 2,
vamos a factorizar ese 2,
que multiplica a "l" más "w",
que quede claro,
éste también es un camino válido parar despejar "w".
Muy bien,
¿qué nos queda ahora?
Podemos dividir entre 2 ambos lados,
dividimos entre 2 ambos lados de la ecuación,
del lado derecho,
2 arriba y 2 abajo se cancelan
y del lado izquierdo
nos queda simplemente "P" sobre 2.
¿Qué tenemos ahora?
Tenemos del lado izquierdo "P" sobre 2...
"P" sobre 2,
lo cual es igual a "l" más "w".
Ahora para despejar "w" restamos "l" a ambos lados
y lo puedes hacer de varias maneras,
lo puedes hacer como aquí
en una línea distinta
o sino lo puedes hacer directamente
sobre la ecuación,
entonces restando "l" del lado
derecho y también del lado izquierdo,
sumamos "-l" que es lo mismo, bien,
del lado derecho "l" y "-l" se cancelan con lo cual
ya quedó despejada "w",
ya tenemos "w"
¿Y del lado izquierdo qué nos queda?
Nos queda "-l" más "P" sobre 2
ó podemos usar la conmutatividad de la suma
para escribir esto como,
"P" sobre 2...
"P" sobre 2 menos "l"
y ésta también es una respuesta totalmente válida.
Tú me podrías decir, "oye Sal, esto se ve
totalmente distinto "P" menos "2l" sobre 2,
se ve diferente que "P" sobre 2 menos "l",
pero no son distintas.
Veámoslo aquí.
Esto lo podemos escribir como...
como "P"...
déjame ponerlo mejor
con el color que tiene originalmente...
Esto es "P" sobre 2...
"P" sobre 2 menos "2l" sobre 2...
"-2l" sobre 2,
estoy separando simplemente esta resta,
"P" sobre 2 menos "2l" sobre 2.
Ahora aquí tenemos "2l" sobre 2,
estos 2 se pueden simplificar
con lo cual nos queda "P" sobre 2...
"P" sobre 2 menos "l"...
"P" sobre 2 menos "l", lo cual es exactamente
lo que habíamos obtenido acá.